Beckman has been doing a lot of work and
he is a legend and he has been president
of bread for the world since 1991 where
he leads large-scale and successful
campaigns to strengthen our country's
political commitment to overcome hunger
and poverty and I know you also involved
in providing policy analysis through the
bread for the world Institute what one
of the great things that you're doing
and I'm sure my other colleagues up here
do as well that is working not just
among the Christian faith communities
but also with Muslim and Jewish groups
which is something I suspect we all
believe in and you two were at the World
Bank and I loved in your article you're
quoting the interviews that one of your
perhaps colleagues did with the poor
which brings me to something that i
think that the senator said in all of us
have said the importance of humanizing
the situation and that first and on lint
it is very appropriate i think that we
get over our arrogance that we have
something to give and this is a matter
of charity it is much more a matter of
partnership and learning and receiving
from from the poor and i know that you
are a believer in that i also know that
you have won awards on that and you are
an ordained lutheran minister so there's
much more to say about you David but I'd
rather hear from you David Beckman
delighted to speak to this room full of
leaders and also we're being videotaped
so lots of faithful people across the
country will be watching us and I that
may be that may be the more important
audience so I want to talk to folks who
are watching this by video too I'm just
thrilled that Senator Coons is the new
chair of the Senate Africa Committee
bread for the world is a grassroots
faith-based movement we organize people
and congregations to push Congress to do
things that are good for hungry and poor
people in Africa around the world also
in our own country so we do a lot of
work with the Africa subcommittee
and and with the senate overall and this
is going to be having Senator Coons as
the chair will be really a great
opportunity to do some good things for
hungry and poor people he cannot do that
by himself it takes a lot of groups and
it also takes people who think about
Africa in a serious way think about what
is our country doing in Africa and push
to get their own elected representatives
everybody's got two senators and one
representative get them to help do some
good things for Africa or or for poor
people generally so bread for the
world's big campaign this year is a push
to in this in this political context to
get bipartisan legislation that will
make our foreign aid more effective in
reducing poverty so whatever amount of
money we decide to spend we want to use
those dollars well and there are some
common-sense reforms that have to do
with accountability transparency
monitoring and evaluation coordination
that but it's hard to get politicians to
take time to revamp systems to make the
systems work better and we think it's
high time that people of faith on both
both Republicans and Democrats all
across the country that we say to our
members of Congress that we want them to
make foreign aid better now senator
Coons is also on the Budget Committee so
he is right at the center of the big
debate that is right now blown
everything else in Washington out of the
water there is a huge push to reduce
deficit spending and rightly so we need
to address the deficit but there is also
a very massive push to do that partly by
slashing programs that help hungry and
poor people so senator Coons mentioned
HR 1 the first
LLL to pass this new house of
representatives that bill proposes to
cut food aid by half so to reduce our
deficit we're going to we're going to
cut the rations of people and refugee
camps around the world it proposes to
cut development assistance by a third it
proposes to cut head start to reduce our
deficit we need to keep kids
preschoolers out of head start it
proposes to cut the WIC program which
provides nutritious food for babies and
pregnant women in our country this is
not necessary and it is not right so the
way to fix that is not senator Coons I
mean God thank God he's there he can
help but the way to fix that is us and
the people watching this video there are
40 days in length that's about just
about six weeks so you've got two
senators one representative you can
write to each of those people and then
write to each of them again in lens
seriously and follow what's going on and
tell them to do what's right for poor
and hungry people we can deal with our
economy without taking food away from
hungry babies this is clear and it is a
perfectly appropriate and correct
observance of lands I think lent is
fundamentally for Christians about
reflection on the suffering and death of
Jesus and what that means in terms of
God's love for us God's love and mercy
for us and so for Christians we can
relax into that mercy and admit that we
have some failings that we need to fix
knowing that God is good and merciful
and will take care of us and I think out
of this land it is absolute
right that we should draw from that
experience of God's goodness real
concern serious concern our country
ought to get more serious about poverty
than it has ever been this is a good
time to start and I'm really glad Linda
I I understand my friend and mentor Tony
Hall you're going to ask him to speak
and he has got a great idea that
everybody ought to hear